24 heures c'est par ces images de celle
que vous allez voir c'est le temps qu'il
faut pour se rendre en train de lyon à
berne
à la 25ème heure j'ai vu le petit jour
se levait sur les paysages de la zone
soviétique puis j'ai aperçu les
premières pierres du mur que gardent les
vopos pour me rendre de la gare
française au secteur américain j'ai
emprunté l'une des autoroutes qui
traversent berlin ouest
ici le coeur de la ville bat au rythme
occidentale berlin-ouest reconstruit
présente l'aspect d'une ville moderne
aux larges artères mais certains
monuments anciens encore debout lui
conserve tout son charme
cependant les berlinois à l'est comme à
l'ouest vivent dans la hantise du mur
depuis le 13 août 1961 werlen a été
coupée en deux par une frontière
inqualifiable sur 45 km 200 le mur se
dresse impénétrable et froid surmonté de
ces barbelés que les rues sont navrants
paradoxe avait acheté aux alliés
occidentaux
l'église de la bernauerstrasse eux les
façades des maisons étaient murées de
funèbre couronne remplacent les fleurs
qui pendait naguère au balcon de berne
à l'est il n'ya pas de feux de
circulation aux carrefours
point n'est besoin les rues sont vides
de l'animation que l'on trouve à l'ouest
et pourtant des deux côtés du mur
la vie continue sur un rythme vibrant
que martèlent les banques des avions à
réaction
autrefois de la rue du 17 juin à l'aller
unter den linden 11 km de lignes droites
offrait aux promeneurs une perspective
majestueuse que seul venait jalonné la
masse imposante de la porte de
brandebourg
aujourd'hui le mur emprisonne même la
porte de brandebourg
un commerçant avant que sa vitrine ne
soient mûrs et a pu placer un éloquente
écriteau que vous allez voir dans
quelques instants
bienvenue à berne
voici le monument russe puis l'ancien
reichstag
enfin la porte de brandebourg
berlin ouest contrairement à berlin-est
est presque entièrement reconstruit les
méthodes d'urbanisme utilisés sont des
plus modernes et de larges espaces verts
ont été partout aménagé
la cité universitaire comporte une
académie des arts où l'esthétique ne le
cède en rien au fonctionnel
berlin ouest possède aussi son palais
des congrès et si vous le voulez bien
nous terminerons ce marathon dans le
berlin d'aujourd'hui d'un côté du mur et
de l'autre par une visite au fameux
stade de cent mille places qui fut jadis
édifié pour les jeux olympiques de 1936
quand les allemands d'aujourd'hui
prennent place sur ces bancs ils songent
qu'à leur réunification
en espérant que le mur ne l'a pas rendu
impossible mais le dernier mot
appartient à l'avenir on voudrait
espérer que les couloirs aériens ne
mèneront pas l'europe de demain la
guerre
que cet avion qui part emmène avec lui
tous nos espoirs de paix